you know for talking about all the
street [__] and all three like it's just
that's just not who you are now yeah
yeah i mean that would be
that would be a falsehood to be talking
[__] like i'm still out there gang
banging and right you know um
living that life i definitely ain't
doing that [__] and even when you were i
think he played it all pretty cleverly
yes because here's the thing right um
and they do it more so now than they
than they used to but
i mean the feds in law enforcement are
listening to everything you're doing
they're watching everything you're
posting
if you're a hip-hop artist
because
some some hip-hop artists will tell on
themselves in a song yeah trying to be
too graphic about it
i want you i want to validate
me by telling you some [__] i did right
and you know
you might think oh well it's a song no
one's really gonna take it serious but
guess what the [__] that are
the law enforcement they take it serious
and if there's a case pending on some
[__] you mentioned that sort of links
you to that
guess what
they're coming at you so
you know you can't you know you'd be
stupid to tell on yourself and tell a
story that is completely
full of all truths if you're going to
tell a story that did happen
you kind of you might want to shake it
up a little bit or not even [__] tell
that story right because realistically
you know
you could put yourself
or your boys or somebody in a twist for
something you said that
you know that needs resolution in terms
of a case right right so
yeah man
you got some guys that just they don't
think about it and they'll put
themselves in a [__] twist by telling
on themselves other guys that are being
really graphic and and telling you this
story as if it [__] happened
yesterday that [__] is made up they
ain't never lived that life they ain't
been one day through it because you
wouldn't be saying such a graphic
[__] story that's true
right you know what i mean because you'd
be telling on yourself
it's called dry snitching
wow we're learning so much today yeah i
love it man this dude this has been so
killer man it's called stevo's hot sauce
for your butthole and if you go on
amazon and type in stevo's hot sauce for
your butthole and order yourself a
bottle you'd be really helping me
because right now we're ranked number 30
on all of amazon and if you buy a bottle
we might go up the ladder and that would
mean a lot so please get on amazon and
buy stevo's hot sauce for your butthole
yeah
yeah dude